it's extraordinary it's magnificent wait
what's that i hear wedding bells that's
because david harbour
and lily allen just said i do yep
e.t can confirm that the 35 year old
singer and the 45 year old actor got
married on monday
the couple obtained their marriage
license in las vegas
and david later shared these wedding
pics on instagram
revealing that they got hitched at
graceland wedding chapel
and yes they had an elvis presley
impersonator
officiate their wedding i'm really
excited for you to see him
the stranger things star infused humor
and sarcasm into the caption writing
quote
in a wedding officiated by the king
himself the people's princess wed her
devoted low-born but kind credit card
holder in a beautiful ceremony lit by
the ashen skies courtesy of a burning
state miles away in the midst of a
global pandemic
refreshments were served at a small
reception following
now that's how you caption a wedding
post people
oh and in and out is for sure the best
wedding meal ever
[Music]
as for lily she shared several snaps too
including this pick in her wedding dress
and this pic chowing down
after their nuptials this marks david's
first marriage while lily was previously
married to builder and decorator sam
cooper
their divorce was finalized in 2018
after seven years of marriage
they share two kiddos together
eight-year-old ethel
and seven-year-old marnie lily and david
have been
romantically linked since last october
when they were spotted kissing in
nyc they later made their red carpet
debut as a couple at the 2020 screen
actors guild awards in january and in
march
david made headlines after he called
lily his wife
during an instagram live you think you
married a pop star
you didn't not that we're married we're
not married i just
yeah they quickly clarified that they
weren't actually technically married
yeah we do my wife we do pretend by may
lily alba confirmed they were engaged
when a fan
asked if that was an engagement ring in
her instapix
her response first rule of engagement
club
which of course is a nod to this line
from fight club
the first rule of fight club is you do
not talk about fight club
lilly recently shared pics from the
family's vacay to croatia
and david shared some sweet shots of him
with his now stepdaughters
on insta